[Musique]
depuis toujours la découverte des
grottes fascine rien de surprenant car
ce monde souterrain constitue un
véritable voyage dans le temps
la grotte de cussac ne fait pas
exception chef-d'oeuvre de l'art grave
et sa découverte remonte à l'automne
2000 il y avait tant la grotte de cussac
se situe en france dans le département
de la dordogne
contrairement à la grotte de lascaux
n'abrite aucune peinture elle contient
plus tôt des gravures paléolithique et
des représentations animales sculpté
dans la roche
vieille de 25 mille ans elle est le
symbole de la période dite graves aux
siennes
on y retrouve quelques 150 mammouth et
rhinocéros servi des bisons et chevaux
la représentation de certains animaux et
de très grande dimension plus de quatre
mètres de long
on a aussi découvert des ossements
humains provenant de quelques individus
sont ils tous membres de la même famille
du même clan on ne sait pas encore
à l'origine c'est en dégageant un
éboulis que l'entrée de la grotte s'est
dévoilée à mark de l'uck et ses
coéquipiers spéléologues de vente eu de
longues galeries s'étendent sur environ
1,5 km il aura fallu dix ans de travaux
préparatoires pour sécuriser les dieux
ce n'est qu'en 2010 que la découverte a
été rendue publique
toujours sous protection
le site est un chantier scientifique un
laboratoire souterrain
pratiques funéraires iconographie la
grotte préservant encore son autre
secret
pour des raisons de sécurité le site a
peu de chances d'être un jour accessible
au public notamment à cause de la
surabondance de gaz carbonique coeur de
la crotte